un intento de fuga frustrado los
funcionarios de inmigración de sri lanka
negaron al controvertido presidente
gotabhaya a raya para abandonar el país
él y otros miembros de su familia
habrían intentado exiliarse tras las
masivas protestas exigiendo su renuncia
si el jefe de estado dimite como se ha
comprometido a hacer el primer ministro
ranil hui cremes inge será nombrado
automáticamente presidente interino
hasta que el parlamento elija a un
miembro para que ejerza el cargo hasta
el final de la legislatura en noviembre
de 2024
pero el actual primer ministro también
se ve desafiado por los manifestantes
que llevan más de meses acampando frente
a la secretaria presidencial
exigiendo la dimisión de todo el
gobierno ante la crisis económica sin
precedentes
la gente no saldrá de la casa del
presidente de la oficina del presidente
o en la residencia oficial del primer
ministro hasta que los líderes anuncien
oficialmente sus dimisiones y no se
marcha en el día 13 de julio lo que
ocurrirá es que la gente decidirá
asaltar el lugar donde se esconden ahora
el presidente rajapaksa es acusado de
mala gestión de la economía lo que ha
llevado three lanka no poder financiar
las importaciones más básicas para sus
22 millones de habitantes
la familia araya vasca gobernó con mano
de hierro desde 2005 hasta 2015 antes de
volver al poder en noviembre de 2019 con
la elección de gotabaya rajapaksa tras
los atentados yihadistas de abril de
2019 en los que murieron más de 250
personas el mandatario se había
presentado como el hombre capaz de
levantar el país con sus retos de
seguridad y económicos pero desde
entonces la nación ha caído en un abismo
financiero y la situación no ha dejado
de empeorar